okay so there's two kuzushi patterns in
Aikido one is the forward inward and
what is the back outward they're related
they correspond to two spirals the
inward spiral and the outer spiral okay
but they are the same as much as yin and
Yan is the same so the forward Edward is
nothing more than the backward outward
in Reverse
don't try to invent new things okay so
we did our ukyo connections oh I'll
bring him around and Kokoro you have the
others follow so this is a great
exercise in trying to develop one
identify the Kazushi pattern to develop
the mode of operation and three to
cultivate the skill both the
coordination and the conditioning okay
so one we're gonna we're not going to do
this anymore like drill one where I'm
just working upon everything should come
from the center so that higher skill is
I'm going to unlock the quarters
beginner skill corner stay lost we see
that higher skill is my organization is
not happening here is happening here so
I can't unlock my door I will they're
more a sequential pull you still have
elbow goes from inverse spiral reversed
and were spiraling Ibaka
this final it does happen uh Elvis more
they have been shoulder so if you watch
my movie shoulder boom incorrect
sequencing with the hippie shoulder
looks like this finger down pinky down
double up along here if you don't move
the shoulder back you're going to get
out of the deltoid so the shoulder Ruth
bow it's like a shoulder goofbot I went
forward bold shoulder goes forward and I
see that so stay with the hip kick went
forward and back hip goes forward and
back so don't come up you go down is
winco's English I II assume so I'm not
pulling this push pulling it no just
open your drift I am here so even he has
closed finger I don't pull I work inside
the grip okay so it's not it's not in my
hat but
it's in my it's in my body so when he's
here on I'm doing you think so he's here
on the door
outside and you see that okay so here
let's let's get rid of here but spring
char elbow so my elbow is very tight
this is never Marshall elbow is very
tight tight boom tight in front of me
ba elbow elbow tight it turns wrong it
turns not out here not out here like
this and my hand does this big circle so
even this one when I free this hip he
pushes into me his energy boom and I'm
around that energy vertically then we
drop okay Bobby my sugar here
nice low stay there my shoulders behind
his head this is gonna be our deltoid
that's not the heart
you have to sequentially free the hips
whoa
[Music]
over here I'm in front and then I'm just
so right this way now go around this way
then bring it back so there's some
things are just round back through me it
just makes me happy that's all they're
good right I'm going to free change it
hip around come back up here comes out
pressure holy I'm gonna go forward
on the inside oh yeah
[Music]
so I'm starting to tilt it you see when
I go like push and I go like that I got
to tilt danver rotate that whole cross
won't well i movie here now so he's like
our two swords we're here and I went
like that I went around his energy over
here oh here comes Bob and the cross
comes again and I'm gonna go around with
energy this way so he's all a trick
I've not not be powerful and if the
opposite go round around him
[Music]
but I'm going to tilt you see see how
I'm doing that all right
energy so just concentrate your own
takes a lot this takes a lot to just
tilt tilt the hip whoa Jerry cogs I go
round it again
do you guys see all right let's try it
hey turn the cross so right now the back
the back our spirals giving us trouble
some of us can't do it because we were
pushing all along in them the wing here
is exposing the help okay but elbow is
around then he goes okay here we go
Taylor I go this way so condition to my
body so elbow is very tight don't have
it loose elbows very very tight I go
forward don't go hard use the I can
teach it and then the arm again it's
gonna cause the tension enjoy energy
vocal through me and I
everybody's all better or not each time
I do you treat me pictures strong and I
feel it so I have to love it but if
there's an elbow so you see how you hey
let's try even body tension even in the
of your self
the tension is revealed even mentally
the tension is real even not doing the
technique physically but mentally you do
[Music]
you go
[Applause]
[Music]